hi my name is Samuel Leeds and I'm so
excited and I've been invited to come
and speak at your local pin meeting I
first came to a pin meeting eight years
ago and within a few years I became
financially free through property and
accumulated over a million pound
portfolio so we're going to be talking
about how to achieve financial freedom
through property and I'm gonna be
explaining exactly how I did it and also
giving you some top strategies that work
how you can become financially free
through property HMOs are one strategy
and I'm going to be explaining how most
people are doing HMOs completely wrong
and how you can do them without a lot of
money and without a lot of headache and
how you can in a thousand pounds per
month per property and we're also going
to be talking about exactly where to buy
what to buy and when is the right time
to invest so you will walk away ready to
be a professional property investor so
we have a great time I look forward to
seeing you there